حصلت على رؤية هذا الآن في اللحظة
التي أنقذ فيها قرار في جزء من الثانية من قبل
سائق مقطورة جرار أرواحًا
، كانت حافلة مليئة
بأطفال المدارس الابتدائية في أوهايو في طريقه ،
انظر
إنها توقفت الآن
[موسيقى
] وتسمع صوته عندما يبدأ الذعر في
يبني عندما يرى الحافلة المدرسية في
طريقه ،
لذا انتقل إلى أسفل وتمكن
من الخروج من طريق الحافلة المدرسية في الوقت المناسب ، على
ما يبدو ، تعطلت
الفرامل ، وقال قائد الشرطة المحلية هناك
إنه بطل حقيقي ،
وتجنب الكارثة بعض التوتر  لحظات الجميع على ما
يرام
[موسيقى]
هذه بالطبع هي النقطة الأفضل من
داخل الحافلة
المدرسية وقد يكون هناك معلم كبير
يقول
إنه سيضربنا ويقول
مرحبًا للأطفال الذين يحاولون إبقاء كل شيء
باردًا مرة أخرى  مكابحه تعطلت لكنه كان
قادرًا على تغيير السرعات وتجنب تلك
الحافلة المدرسية في الوقت المناسب
وقائد الشرطة يقول حقًا
إنه بطل